the jurogan experience let's
let's uh establish your position alex on
on on covet what is your position on
this
sure so people accuse me of being a
covet denialist
or you know i don't think it's real i
don't think anyone dies from it that's
that's all nonsense joe yeah covet is
real it uh
you know it emerged from we can talk
about where it might have emerged from
uh earlier this year maybe in late 2019
it's killed a lot of people um it's
contagious
and uh and and you know it's been a
problem this year it's been a
significant problem
yeah it is not worthy of the response
that we have had to it i believe
lockdowns have been a mistake and we can
go into all of it but
but we have overreacted in an extremely
dangerous way this year
i believe we've overreacted as well and
i i think that
in particular one of the things that
disturbs me the most is that there's
been
no accounting for the damage that has
been done
by forcing people to shut down their
businesses and
their only the only thought has been
making sure that the icu beds are open
and that you know somehow or another
people are able to get
treatment for this there's been i've
openly criticized the fact there's been
no discussion whatsoever about
getting healthy like this not no one's
encouraging you because they're worried
about being called a fat shamer
or some other nonsensical term well i
mean i think it's much worse than that
because if
if you remember back in may or back in
march we were told
15 days 15 days to slow the spread let's
not have the hospitals be overrun
and at some point maybe it was in april
maybe it was in may somehow this became
no one can ever get sick
and die from covid it is wrong that this
disease exists and we have to do
everything to stop
it no matter what the consequences and
you mentioned businesses businesses are
important
but to me what's even more important is
what we're doing to our kids yeah what
we've done with school closures
what we've done with normalizing the
idea that being outside with your
friends is dangerous
we are we are we are screwing over our
kids in the worst possible way
i think we had an idea of what coveted
was going to be
i don't know i certainly did for the
first few weeks i was like this is going
to kill everybody
i thought i was going to kill 10 of the
population i was really worried about it
i remember being in the supermarket
stocking up
and thinking jesus christ like this this
feels so crazy but i also remember
thinking it was going to last two weeks
yep
and now here we are still reacting this
way
we're now deep into january or deep into
december almost into january
um a lot of my friends were caught
including young jamie over here
and jamie beat it in a day uh tony
hinchcliffe has it now
he was sick yesterday and today feels
good
and this is the case with so many people
whereas if they got the flu
i knew i know a lot of the same people
that have got the flu they were knocked
down into the dirt for three or four
days maybe a week maybe two weeks
um it's different than we thought it was
going to be but we're still reacting
like it was the same thing
and then there's this this fear porn
that everybody likes to peddle it's this
weird thing where everybody wants to
think that you know
if you catch it you have a 10 chance of
dying or the sky is falling and
it's just it's weird how uh
people want to pretend that it's still
what it used to be
and they want to say you know you should
think about this because 300 000
americans have died you want to go stop
no 300 000 americans have died
from covid that also had a lot of other
stuff
how many people have died just from
covet and it's a
relatively small number in comparison
it's like a bad flu year right um
so it's complicated here's here's the
thing and and um
and i don't know if you if you and you
know this is as i said about all this
stuff for you but
the the the booklets i especially the
first one which is about how
death counting how we go how we count
akova death go i go into this in detail
okay well let's talk about that right
away so okay
there's here's the most fundamental fact
about covid that the media
doesn't report accurately how stratified
the
risk is by age so you mentioned you
mentioned you know people who are who
might be overweight or have diabetes all
that stuff does add to your risk
what really adds to your risk is age and
people and people don't really
i think this is true of almost everybody
people don't really have a good idea of
what
what risk is right so if i say you know
like
it's riskier to be old and have covert
than to be young you might think okay
it's like two to one or three to one or
five to one it's kind of like normal
risks like
what are the odds that the jets are
going to beat the rams like 1 in 10
you know last week and that happened the
jets beat the rams
this risk is not like that it's like
somewhere between a hundred and ten
thousand times the risk
of what age so
maybe 75 versus 25 80 versus 25
if you look at who dies from this it is
overwhelmingly
people over 65 75
85 okay the the median age of death
in in european countries or you know
which are a little bit healthier than
the us
is in the low 80s but that doesn't
really tell you
the real risk because what you need to
understand is that only two or three
percent of the population
is over 82 or 83. now what about people
like there was that guy who's a broadway
actor
who was a young healthy looking guy who
got sick and wound up dying from it
so that's going to happen so there's two
issues first of all that happens to
people with the flu i can point you to
stories from 2018
what you know young healthy teacher dies
of the flu it just was never reported
nationally this way
that's a b is if you look at those cases
oftentimes there's weird idiosyncratic
stuff happening of which the number one
thing is a lot of those people were put
on ventilators
very early they were put on ventilators
and they never came off
we're not having that as much anymore
and if you look the average age of death
is actually creeping up
now it looks like and okay so that's one
is that the risk
you talk about that yes the ventilators
yeah so what happened
so what happened was in march especially
back when everybody was terrified
there's there there's there's something
called a nebulizing procedure
so there are procedures that that where
you're where you're inserting tubes into
people and it releases a lot
of um you know aerosols from them and
the fear was
this is going to get aerosolized and the
nurses and the doctors are all going to
get sick and die and we're going to have
no medical staff
ventilator avoids that problem okay so
the
the feeling was let's ventilate very
early this is a really serious disease
let's get everybody
we can on ventilators that's when
remember when we needed a hundred
thousand ventilators two hundred
thousand ventilators
that was the idea okay we're gonna
ventilate really early
turns out that was a terrible idea it
turns out that
as as elon musk likes to say you know
your lungs
if you ventilate too early it's just
like a meat bellows and you can blow out
people's lungs if you over ventilate
and it looks like that happened i will
tell you not that we're no
not that we don't use ventilators for
covid but right now in the united states
i believe there are about 8 000 people
on ventilation can you now can i stop
you for a second like meat bellows so
like bellows like a fireplace bellows
right so you're just pushing this air in
and you're and like if you push it in at
pressure that's too high you can just
blow out people's lungs so you
literally destroy their lungs yes yes we
did that with people and
and and it became clear it became pretty
clear pretty early on and and they
and they tried to stop doing it and they
have stopped doing it you know that's
why they were saying that 80 percent of
the people they put on veterinarians
went up dying
it's not just that they were so sick by
the time they got to ventilators they
were dying
that's right and they couldn't save them
it was just that the
ventilators themselves did damage that's
wow
that and i don't think that actually too
many people would argue that even
in hospitals i can point you to stories
that have been written about this and i
can point you to sort of
in hospital discussion of this um again
there is a role for ventilators for
people who really cannot breathe on
their own
but this early ventilation that we that
we used back in march and april
killed people and some of the people
killed are people who were younger who
probably would have survived
my friend michael yo was young when he
got it and he was really beaten down he
did a lot of traveling he flew to new
york
he did morning radio the whole deal flew
back drove to vegas
visited his family and then drove home
that night and then did a bunch of
auditions in la and then got sick
real sick his doctor didn't put him on a
ventilator because he said if i put you
on a ventilator your lung is going to
stop working
and you're going to die and he's okay
today because of that yep
but he's a young healthy robust guy
and he got it and almost died i mean he
was really really sick for about two
weeks so
so but he recovered yeah right so so
again we're not saying this disease
isn't real and we're not saying that
some people unfortunately aren't going
to have these bad reactions to it
but but you know back in march maybe he
gets put on a ventilator and maybe he
dies
well he got it very very early so that
was so he so he was fortunate he had a
doctor who was smart yeah
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience